kevin first of all this has to be a
dream come true to you or did you ever
dream that this was possible that you
could fill your dad's seat here at unlv
yeah very hopeful and uh always a goal
to first you know be a head coach in
college and continue to progress on that
path but then
to be able to do it here always
something that you know
was something that we talked about and
wanted and
was it wasn't necessarily in any rush to
do but
definitely something that excited about
and and just with the familiarity of the
city
playing here as a running rebel and
knowing what it's like
um that there's a certain level of
comfort to and understanding
in in terms of the the job and the
program and the and the community and
the history
and so it was definitely something that
always wanted to do
um and to have the opportunity now uh
just just couldn't be more excited
what were some of your best experiences
that one year plane under your dad here
obviously went went to the sweet 16 in
st louis there but
what were some of your experiences
perhaps that we we may not be aware of
well i think the what comes to mind the
most in that year is just the the way we
started out
and and the way that the city and the
community and the and the alumni and the
and the former players just
how quickly everybody came back and came
together and
uh the the level of support and
just the the love for unlv that that
everybody had kind of talked about
uh you know my dad had been been here
for two years and everybody kind of knew
it nationally from following
tark's team's uh and that great run of
success that he had
but then to witness it and to be a part
of it
just is the is the most just
vivid memory that i have just just the
amount of support and love that we got
uh as the season went on and we
continued to to climb nationally and
then eventually in the tournament
i'm gonna go back 10 years when your dad
left here it seems like he didn't want
to leave here that he had had genuine
love for this community oklahoma had to
beg him
you know three times to finally and then
keep and get the money up
doing him out but but it was tough for
him to leave here and he had a genuine
love for this community
you share that same affinity absolutely
i mean this is where we've always wanted
to be you know uh
after playing here just that one year uh
getting a home
here in vegas to kind of make my home
base personally
and even after he went on to oklahoma
still having that house here
so then i came back in the summers if i
was overseas or
here in the states to to make this my
home base personally so
you know the love for vegas uh always
called it home
since uh since 2007 after leaving here
so
uh i i would say that you know he
definitely and
my mom absolutely love vegas but i'm i'm
right there with him if not
if not even higher do you see yourself
being here for a long time i know that's
hard to say you're just
you're three days into the job now i
mean hopefully it's my decision but
absolutely
you know we want this to be home as long
as it can possibly be and we
and we want to make it work and uh you
know there is no
but to yeah to your point there is no
other job that it's it feels
that when i talk with with allie or or
my parents or whoever it may be that
you know well if we get this thing going
you know maybe we can get to
blank you know there's none of that you
know we want to be here
you know the the pride of being a
running rebel
uh as a player and now the pride of
being as a coach is
is uh it's just special there's
there's a few people myself probably
included in this that think there may
have been some planning in this that
you take the job here your dad all of a
sudden retires
that maybe it was sort of uh perhaps
organized so that he could come here
and have a role on your coaching staff
at all
do you ever do you see that happening um
i mean if he would like to be a
volunteer assistant
we we'd welcome him with open arms but
yeah i'm not sure how much of that
specific planning went into it on
on the other side but uh no i mean and
just like anyone
you know if anybody's got a mentor in
basketball
that has experience and relationships
and
and and advice you know we'll welcome
him
and the fact that that he he just
happens to be my dad
as well as a mentor and a former coach
of mine
it really doesn't change anything you
know if somebody can can add value to
the program and and give us some insight
or
you know take a second to look at it
from the outside uh an outsider's
perspective and and we take that and we
feel it can help our program we'll we'll
welcome it with
open arms so so perhaps more than just a
fan in the stands maybe sometime
on the bench you ever think that now
let's go
i could have seen that scenario i hadn't
but
uh i don't know maybe maybe we need to
bring it up
but uh you know i'm sure he'll be pretty
happy here
especially early to be in the in the
stands with my mom
uh with my wife my daughter uh
just just being a fan and cheering your
dad
and jerry tarkanian seem to have a great
relationship an admiration a friendship
with each other i talked to both of them
about it when they were both here um do
you share that same affinity i mean you
were just a kid when the rebels
won the national championship of course
i don't expect you to remember that
stuff but
you you have that same affinity towards
the program from back then
oh absolutely i think uh you know i
remember growing up and pretending to be
greg anthony in anderson high in in the
driveway
you know shooting after watching games
uh you know inside uh
and just that that that love for the
community and the in the former players
uh
was just it was always a cornerstone of
my dad's
and and i think i and i learned that you
know being around him but also
experiencing it and watching
the uh the effect it can have when the
community and the
and the alumni and the former players
all can kind of come together and be
a part of the program and and
and i know i just know the effect it can
have on the guys as well
and the players and the appreciation
because you know
if if we can get the guys to have former
players come and talk to them
and just share their stories and their
experiences
it doesn't do anything but strengthen
that love and that bond with unlv
because while you're doing it as a
player that you know time goes fast
and things are moving and always you
know you're kind of here to there and
and just kind of still trying to figure
out life and and figure things out
but when a former player can kind of
come and tell you you know hey in 15
years
you know the best nights i still have
are when we get back together
and we and we watch a rebel game or we
or we share stories or
you know those reunions and we you know
we talk about coming to practice and
supporting you guys or
we look forward to a game on a calendar
each year when we all get back together
and
and just kind of impress that upon the
team and the players and
and just let them know how important it
is not just for now and
and that continued gel of the team for
you know
current success but how it can go going
forward 15 20 years down the line in
their life
what kind of rebel basketball team do
you see yourself coaching what style
honestly like we've talked about i i
just think
i think we've just got to have a team
that when when our opponent leaves the
game
and their coaches are in the their
locker room they're saying man those
guys love to play
those guys love to compete they love to
play for each other
they play so hard you know you can tell
that they they hate to lose
and um you know i just vis i don't
envision necessarily you know a running
gun or a full court press per se
at this point in time but i do envision
just
just diving on the floor making plays
for each other just having a certain uh
reputation and a mentality that
you know that we hate to lose we hate to
lose and we love to compete
and and if we can just do that and have
that as our starting block
going forward with guys coming in or and
every day in practice i
i i truly think the wins will come and
it because i do feel it's a mentality
because that that how you do that
anything part in life you know is how
you do everything
and if we compete in the drills and we
compete in the scrimmages
you know we'll compete in games and uh
and come out with some wins
there's there seems to be an optimism
over the last three days in this
community
for rebel basketball i've i've heard it
and seen it felt it
i i would imagine you have as well
have you yeah there's been a great uh
you know outreach of support and love in
the community um
from former players to fans uh it's
really been
it just kind of makes me smile you know
it's been it's been happy and and
exciting
and and to get that feedback you know
from
you know people that are now you know
members of the community that were
students when i was here
or people who have been season ticket
holders for 20 30 40 years and uh
and the the love and support that we've
gotten so far has been unbelievable
and uh we really just it just really
kind of reminds you
you know of of who the the team is
playing for
and and and and it's not going lost you
know and we that's why we got to make
sure we go to go out
we got to bring people into the program
that that represent that mentality
and represent that love and that care
your dad held his
farewell news conference in oklahoma
today little emotional
at times that doesn't surprise you
though does it no he's a softy he's a
softy no but uh
it doesn't you know i mean he's been
coaching as long as i can remember
you know he was a head coach when i was
born in in south texas
so uh you know for it's a long way to
think about personally but you can
imagine
you know having doing something for that
long and it being that ingrained in your
life and
you know all the trips we took growing
up were because of basketball
um all the places we got to see and the
people we got to meet were because of
basketball they were centered around
where he was coaching or what
organization he was involved in and uh
so so to think about that kind of
you know coming to an end it's got to be
it's got to be overwhelming and
emotional and
but uh i know he's excited to get out
here and support unlv and and he's
happy and and as a son i don't really
know what else you could hope for
how soon are they coming out here
they're coming out they have the new
place out at southern highlands
yeah um it'll be a good question i
i mean maybe if there's another bad
stretch of weather you know my mom might
be out here a little sooner but uh
i'm not sure we haven't we haven't
talked about it we haven't talked about
i know my wife will be trying to get him
out here pretty quick though
any other thoughts anything else that
you want to share with
no i just just just hope to just come
support him you know come support the
guys
i know it means a lot to them and uh
hopefully with with covet allowing it we
can
get out into the community and we can
have practices open back up and uh
we can really get out and mingle and and
be intertwined with the community like
unlv basketball always has
and uh i really just really want to do
that and
so hopefully kobe permitting we can uh
you know open some things up in the fall
and and get everybody out here and get
them to see their rebels
right coach thanks thank you